[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل
البدايه من رام الله
سعيد الاحتلال في جنين
ومن وارسو يوافينا فريق الجزيره هناك بهذه
الصور فولندا اصبحت محطه الانظار بعد
موافقه عدد من الدول على تزويد اوكرانيا
مختلفه من الدبابات
اما هذه الصور ستصلون من الخرطوم التي
زارها اليوم رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي
احمد والتقى فيها قياده مجلس السياده
وعددا من الاطراف السياسيه السودان
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
فقتي حامل جديد لمدينه جنين ومخيمها قوه
الاحتلال تقتل تسعه فلسطينيين وتصيب
العشره
[تصفيق]
السلطه الفلسطينيه
مع اسرائيل
والفصائل تتواعد بالانتقام
والخارجيه الامريكيه تقول
زيارته للمنطقه على وقت العنف والحفاظ على
الوضع التاريخي للاقصى
في مستوى جديد من الانقسام بين المؤسسات
القضائيه اللبنانيه مجلس القضاء الاعلى
يخفق في الاجتماع لبحث التحقيقات في قضيه
مرفا بيروت
اشتباكات بين اهالي ضحايا الانفجار وقوات
الامن والمحقق العدلي في القضيه يعلن
للجزيره استمراره في عمله ورفضه الاستجابه
لاستدعاء النائب العام له
[موسيقى]
غدا اعلاني واشنطن وعواصمه غربيه تزويد
القوات الاوكرانيه بدبابات متطوره
[تصفيق]
من طراز الايباد و 200 عربه مدرعه لقياس
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه تطالب بمزيد من
قطاع المدفعيه لاستهداف الامدادات الروسيه
القادمه من القرم والقوه الروسيه تكثف
قصفها على العاصمه
ومناطقه الجنوب والشرق بالصواريخ
والمسيرات
مباحثات في الخرطوم بين رئيس مجلس السياده
ورئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيه بيان سودانيون
اثيوبيين مشترك ينص على اتفاق الطرفين على
معالجه القضايا الثنائيه بما فيها الحدود
عبر الحوار والبرهان يؤكد وجود اتفاق
وتوافق بين الخرطوم واديس ابابا بشان
القضايا المتعلقه بسد النهضه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تنظيم عدد من اهالي ضحايا
بيروت وقفه احتجاجيه دعما لما صارت تحقيق
الذي استنفه المحقق طارق البيطار واتهم
سلطات بعرقله التحقيق الملف ياتي ذلك في
وقت اخفق فيه المجلس الاعلى للقضاء في
الاجتماع للاطلاع على قرارات المحقق العدل
طارق البيطار لطلب من وزير العدل في حكومه
تصنيف الاعمال هنري الخوري
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
الثالث برايكم ما السبب وراء المواجهه
القضائيه بشان قضيه تجاري مرئي بيروت
62 في المئه قالوا ان الاسباب سياسيه
بينما قال 5% فقط ان الامر يعود لخلافه
قانونيه وارجع ثلاثه وثلاثون في المئه
الاسباب الى مصالحه ذاتيه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمزي كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصه الرقميه
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
سيجال فرنسي روسي محوره منطقه الساحل
الافريقيه لافروض يتهم باريس بدعم الارهاب
والخارجيه الفرنسيه تقول ان تصريحاته
اكاذيب مخزيه
[موسيقى]
داخل مدينه جنين ومخينها في الضفه الغربيه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم عمليه
عسكريه كبيره اسفلت واثقه وزاره الصحه
واصابه عشرات بعضهم في حاله خطيره من جهه
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان العمليه
العسكريه استهدفت ثلاثه مطلوبين من حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي
يوم دام في مخيم الجن شهداء وجرحى
بالعشرات ودمار خلفه جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في اقتحام وصفات
الكبير عام 2002 يقول الجيش الاحتلال ان
معلومات استخباراتيه دلته على مكان وجود
ثلاثه من المطلوبين
وسرعان ما وقع اشتباك مسلح بين جنود
الاحتلال ومقاومين اخرين وصلوا الى المكان
بس زي اليوم
اعقل احتلال دخول فرق الاسعاف الى المخيم
وانتشال الجرحى والشهداء يتحدث شهود عيان
عن ترويع الناس والاعتداء على ممتلكاتهم
مركباتهم وهم داخلها في سلوك الانتقام
معهم جرافه
بالسيارات وطحلب السيارات
خرجوا الناس في وداع الشهداء ونددت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه كافه بما سمته جرائم
الاحتلال وهو استنكار لم يخلو من توجيه
لهم للمجتمع الدولي على صمته حيل ما يجري
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المنافق العدد الكبير من الشهداء والجرحى
يعكس في نظر الفلسطينيين نجاح حكومه
اليمين التي تتعامل مع الوضع الامني
بشراسه لارضاء خلفائها من اقصى اليمين
المتطرف وهو من شانه ان يضع الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله على شفا الفجار كبير
منذ شهور يقمع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الفلسطينيين بالحديد والنار وكل ما صعد من
عمليات الدم والاعتقالي والقتل يقول
الفلسطينيون انه سيجدوا امامه شعبان لا
يخشى الموجهه ويصر على المقاومه
الامنيه مع اسرائيل لم يعد قائما وقال ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه ستتوجه للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لاضافه ملف مجزره جنين
الى الملفات السابقه وانها ستتحرك على كل
المستويات من اجل الشعب الفلسطيني
في ضوء العدوان المتكرر على ابناء شعبنا
والضرب عرض الحائط للاتفاقات الموقعه بما
فيها الامنيه نعتبر ان التنسيق الامني مع
حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما
اعتبارا من الان
ان التنسيق الامني ما حكومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما اعتبارا من الان
وفي هذا السياق نحيي ابناء المؤسسه
الامنيه على مواقفهم المشرفه دفاعا عن
مشروعنا الوطني ومصالح شعبنا كما نحيي
المؤسسات والفعاليات الوطنيه التي تسهر
على المقاومه الشعبيه السلميه وتدعوها
للمزيد حمايه لابناء شعبنا ومقدراته في
مواجهه ارهاب المستوطنين وقوى الاحتلال
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بدورها توعدت الجيش
الاسرائيلي عقيب عمليه جنين حيث قال
الامين العام لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي في
فلسطين زياد النخاله ان العدوان
الاسرائيلي على الشعب الفلسطيني لن يوقف
المقاومه وان مقاتلي الشعب الفلسطيني
سيبقون في الميدان حركه حماس قالت ان
الجيش الاحتلال لن يفلح في كسر اراده
الشعب الفلسطيني وقال نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي للحركه صالح العروري ان الاحتلال
سيدفع ثمن المجزره التي نفذها في جنينه
ومخيمها وان رد المقاومتي لن يتاخر
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان قرار سلطه
الفلسطينيه تعليقه تنسيق الامني مع
اسرائيل ليس في محله كما ان اللجوء الى
مجلس الامن ليس السبيل لمعالجه الوضع
واكدت ان المسؤولين الامريكيين تواصلوا مع
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
لحسهم على خفض التوتر افراد اقتحام جنين
وكانت الخارجيه الامريكيه قد قالت ان
الوزير انطوني لينكن سيبدا الاحد المقبل
جوله تشمل اسرائيل والضفه الغربيه ومصر
وانه سيؤكد في لقاءاته الحاجه الملحه لان
يتخذ الطرفان خطوات لتهدئه التوترات من
اجل وضع حد لدائره العنف التي اودت بحيه
العديد من الابرياء حسب تعبيريا واضحه
الوزاره يناقش اهميه الحفاظ على الوضع
التاريخي الراهن
للحرم الشريف في القدس كما سيبحث مع
الاسرائيليين الدعم الامريكيه دائم لامل
اسرائيل لاسيه ما ضد الخطر الايراني وفق
ما اعلنت الوزاره
افاد مراسل الجزيره ان الامارات والصين
وفرنسا طلبت رسميا من رئيس مجلس الامن
الدولي عقد مشاورات مغلقه للمجلس يوم غد
الجمعه بشان التطورات في جنين من جهه قل
المندوب الفلسطيني لدى الامم المتحده رياض
منصور ان فلسطين تدعو الى عقد جلسه طارئه
لمجلس الامن بشان الجنين واضاف ردا على
سؤال للجزيره ان على مجلس الامن التحرك في
هذا الشان في ايطاليا قرارات المجلس ذاته
وقرارات الجمعيات العامه وتوصيات الامين
العام للامم المتحده
نحن في بدايه التحرك
وسنتواصل مع الجميع و نستمع للجميع
وان نامل ان يرتقي مجلس الامن الى المستوى
الذي الذي يرينا شيئا جديدا يرينا خطوات
عمليه ملموسه في تنفيذ الطلب بتوفير
الحمايه للسكان المدنيين تحت الاحتلال الى
ان يتم كنس هذا الاحتلال عن ارضنا وانجاز
الاستقلال لدوله فلسطين وعاصمه القدس
الشرقيه
ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور غسان
الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرزيت وامنه واشنطن اساطير بيجي كراولي
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
نبدا معك دكتور غسان الخطيب
هل هي المره الاولى التي تعلن السلطه
الفلسطينيه وقفت تنسيق الامن مع اسرائيل
والى متى سيستمر وقت هذا التنسيق برايك
لا هي ليست المره الاولى ولا اعتقد ان هذا
الاجراء او هذه الخطوات يعني مهمه وذات
مغزى لانه كل ما يسمى بالتنسيق الامني هو
مجرد فقاعه اعلاميه اكثر من ما هي امر
حيوي او مهم همم خصوصا للجانب الاسرائيلي
الذي يعتمد عاده على نفسه في النواحي
الامنيه ولا يعتمد على جهات اخرى همم ولا
على التنسيق مع جهات اخرى خصوصا السلطه
الفلسطينيه ولكن الموضوع يضخم ربما لاسباب
دعائيه ولاسباب سياسيه ال- ال- الاجراء
الاكثر اهميه مما قررت السلطه هو الاتجاه
لمجلس الامن والاتجاه لمحكمه الجنايات
لانه هذا هو ما يعني يلحق الاذى الاكبر
باسرائيل لانه هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي
سيؤدي الى ان تدفع ثمن اسرائيل على
وعلاقتها الخارجيه مثلا موضوع التطبيع
العربي وهو مشروع اسرائيلي حيوي سوف يتاثر
سلبا بسبب هذا التصعيد او الاجرام
الاسرائيلي ايضا ربما ستعود القضيه
الفلسطينيه الى اروقه المؤسسات الدوليه
بعد ان غابت وسيكون هناك احراج دبلوماسي
لاصدقاء اسرائيل نتيجه هذا الاجرام
والمبالغه في عمليه القتل اما موضوع
التنسيق الامني فهو الاقل اهميه في كل ما
يجري ولكن الولايات المتحده همم تعتبر بان
لا تنسيق الامن او وقت التنسيق الامن في
محله ولا حتى الذهاب الى مجلس الامن ايضا
همم مفيد او هو الحال جدا هذا الموقف يعني
اذا كان لا تنسيق الامن ولا الذهاب الى
مجلس الامن وبطبيعه الحال موقف الولايات
المتحده همم ضد مقاومه اسرائيل فبالتالي
ما هو الحل من وجهه نظر الولايات المتحده
كيف يتصرف الفلسطينيون اذا
كان هذه مره اخرى كارثه اخرى يفقد فيها
ابرياء حياتهم في هذه المنطقه
لكنه في الحقيقه ليس بديلا عن التفاوض
المباشر بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
وهنا تكمن المعظم بعوده حكومه
بعد ان تم اثبات
الرئيس عباس بينهما علاقات صعبه للغايه
اذا هنا نجد انفسنا اذا هذا القضيه
معه لا يحمل معه هدف المضيق قدما للامام
بعمليه السلام لانه لا توجد عمليه السلام
لكن فقط يحاول ان يضمن ان الامور لا تسوق
اكثر وهذا يدفعني الى ايضا في هذا المجال
يعني حتى الولايات المتحده التي لا تحمل
همم لا يحمل وزيرها شيئا في هذه الزياره
ترفض او حتى تنتقد الذهاب نحو المؤسسات
الشرعيه الدوليه التي لطالم الولايات
المتحده دعت الى تمسك بها اين المشكله لو
لجات همم السلطه الفلسطينيه الى المؤسسات
الدوليه الى مجلس الامن والامم المتحده
وحتى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اين
المشكله في ذلك
فلسطيني فلسطيني
[موسيقى]
وايضا الموقف الامريكي تجاه فلسطين قد تم
اضعافه كثيرا اذا نحن محصرون في نطاق من
الافعال وردود الافعال التي نراها الان
دكتور غسان ما رايك في ان الموضوع همم غير
مفيد
وبالتالي كيف تنظر الى ما قامت به اسرائيل
اليوم في جنين والهدف من هذه العمليه
العسكريه في ظل حكومه هي الاكثر تطرفا في
اسرائيل
اولا هذه العمليه هي استمرار
لسياسه اسرائيليه جديده همم تعتمد على
القتل ومزيد من القتل والتصعيد ودفع
الامور الى اقصى غايات الحده والمواجهه
اما السبب من وجهه نظري فيعود الى الاوضاع
الداخليه في اسرائيل اسرائيل فيها انقسام
غير مسبوق في تاريخها
وتتسابق وتتنافس التيارات السياسيه
المختلفه على اجتذاب تعاطف الجمهور من
خلال الانتقال من موقف متطرف الى موقف
اكثر تطرف يعني المواقف والسياسات
الشعبويه هي التي اضحك الوسيله الاساسيه
لكسب التاييد ولذلك مع اشتداد الانقسام
الاسرائيلي سوف يزداد اتجاه اسرائيل
للتعبير عن سياسات اكثر تصرف وممارسات
اكثر تتطرف واجرام لتحقيق غايات تنافسيه
حسبيه داخليه في اسرائيل وهذا سيعود على
اسرائيل نهايه المطاف بالاذى لانه سيمس
بمكانه اسرائيل وعلاقتها الخارجيه خصوصا
وانه الشعب الفلسطيني لا يسكت يعني سيستمر
في رفض هذا الاحتلال وسيستمر في مقاومته
بكل الاشكال المتاحه واا ربما ايضا يتجه
مجددا للمؤسسات الدوليه من اجل محاوله حشد
قدر اكبر من التعليم الدولي الذي ضعفه في
الفتره الاخيره للقضيه الفلسطينيه شكرا
للتضامن مع الشعب الفلسطيني
في جامعه بيرزيت وشكرا للسفير بيتجي
كراولي المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه كان معنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه سنتوقف مطولا عند مخيم
جنين وفصائل المقاومه عمليات الاحتلال
وقصص الصوم
[موسيقى]
في اوجه ازمه جديده في الوسط القضائي لم
يتمكن مجلس القضاء الاعلى في لبنان من
الالتئام بسبب رفض عدد من اعضاء
ضغط الشارع وتوتر الناجمه عن القرارات
القضائيه التي صدرت خلال اليومين الماضيين
وقد شهد محيط وقصر العدل تدافع عن بين قوه
الامن ومحتاجين على القرارات القضائيه
الصادره عن النائب العام بحق المحقق
العدلي في قضيه انفجار بيروت طارق البيطار
اثارت قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت غضب الشارع
اللبناني مجددا
عندما تخلي قصر العدل اصطدم محتجون مع قوى
الامن قبيله اجتماع بمجلس القضاء الاعلى
فهؤلاء يعتقدون ان التطورات القضائيه
الاخيره تهدف الى تنحيه المحقق العدلي في
قضيه المرفق طارق البيطار
لكن مجلس القضاء اعلى سلطه قضائيه في
لبنان والذي كان من المفترض ان يناقش
القرارات الاخيره التي اتخذها المحقق
العدلي فشل في الالتئام مجلس القضاء
يشرح المشروع بصير داخل القضاء يشرح من
القضاء ومن القوانين هستيريا قضائيه
قانونيه ومش عارفين كيف بدنا نوقف ونعطي
امل للناس ولهذا استمرت قرارات النائب
العام ساريه المفعول بكفي يد القاضي
البيطار عن القضيه والادعاء عليه بتهمه
اغتصاب السلطه
قرارات يراها المحقق العدلي مخالفه
للقانون ويؤكد استمراره في عمله حتى
اصداره القرار الاتهامي في القضيه هذه
المواجهه القضائيه بين نيابه العامه
والمحقق العدلي اثارات الخشيه من
ارتداداتها على مجمد العمل القضائي في
لبنان
حياته كان في قرارات هالقد متناقضه لدرجه
انه
شخصيه بين الاوضاعات وهذه بدها تكسر سلمان
القرارات القضائيه المتباينه في ملف
انفجار المرفق زادت من تعقيدات القضيه
التي لم يصدر فيها قرار اتهاما بعد نحو
عامين ونصف على الانفجار وعززت خشيه اهالي
الضحايا من طي صفحه التحقيق دون كشف
ملابساتها ومحاكمه المتورطين فيها ايهاب
العقد الجزيره بيروت
ينضم الينا من بيروت طوني بولس الباحث
والمحلل السياسي ومن بيروت ايضا ينضم
الينا طارق عبود الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ونبدا معك سيد طارق عمليا هل يمكن القول
ان التحقيق في انفجار همم مرفا بيروت غدا
انتهى بعد اخلاء سبيل الموقوفين
والادعاء من النائب العام على المحقق
العدل في القضيه
تحياتي استاذ حسن لك ولاستاذ طوني بطريقه
ثانيه خلينا نقول انه في مشكله حياتنا
اصبح هناك مشكله حقيقيه على مستوى القضاء
على مستوى يعني التحقيق والوصول الى
النتائج في جريمه مرفا بيروت في العام
2020 السياق القضائي القانوني
القضاه منذ بدايه او بعد الانفجار يعني
اخذ مناحي متعدده وصلنا الى هذه اللحظه
التاريخيه الحقيقه اللحظه السياسيه
والقضائيه والقانونيه نحن في خضام يعني
صراع سياسي وصراع قضائي وصراع قانوني
ودستوري هناك
همم يعني همم يطلب بها او يدلي بها
الاطراف وكل جهه سياسيه وكل راي
همم يستشهد وياتي بشواهد اا تدعم حجته
القانونيه والدستوريه وهي حجه ايضا يعني
سياسيه ذلك اليوم ربما سيد طارق المشاهدين
ربما ربما تبقى هنا الخلفيه السياسيه وانت
اشارت الى الخلاف السياسي هي المتحكمه بكل
همم هذا المشهد الذي يتخذ من انقسام
القضاء مظهرا له
طبيعي لكي نكون واقعيه هناك انقسام سياسي
عمودي في لبنان ولكن حتى يعني طائفه في
موضوع همم جريمه بيروت هناك انقسام قضائي
يعني المجلس القضاء الاعلى لمن عقد اليوم
ولم ينعقد في الجلسات السابقه لعدم يعني
حصول نصاب لانه هناك انقسام في في جسم
مجلس القضاء الاعلى ايضا في في الجسم
القضائي كل الامور تسياس في لبنان لها
خلفيات سياسيه ليس هناك امور قضائيه او
قانونيه او دستوريه او تشريعيه خالصه هناك
تدخل سياسي بالقضاء بالقانون وكل هذه
التفاصيل يعني لبناني يعيش على على
السياسه كل قضيه تدخل فيها هذه
التفاصيل السياسيه وحتى تف التي تاخذ منها
مناح ان طائفيه جريمه مرفا بيروت اخذت
منحا طائفيا كبيرا
طيب هنا سيد طوني بولس
بلى يحق للمتوجهين من همم تحقيقات المحقق
العدلي ان اا يعملوا فعلا على اقصائه كما
يقولون باعتبار انه يستهدف جهه دون غيرها
وان
استدعاءاته
واتهاماته تصب ل همم باتجاه طرف دون اخر
مساء الخير يعني بكل تاكيد كل قضاء وكل
اليه قضائيه لديها اليه اخرى للمراجعه
وليد التوصل وليحقيق العداله واعطاء الفرص
لجميع المدعى عليهم او المتهمين لابدئي
ادله براءتهم او قراءه براءتهم ولكن من
الواضح ان الامور بعكس ذلك تماما من
الوالها ان هناك استهداف في تحقيقات
المرفق بدات منذ انفجار المرفق فاذا نذكر
يوم انفجار المرفا كان هناك معلومات عن
توجهه اني
طوق امني من قبل ميليش حزب الله على
المرفق وصاحب بعض المعدات المهمه جدا التي
لديها ربما ابعاد او دلالات معينه
وباستمر هذا الوضع لمده ثلاث ساعات وبعد
ذلك كان هناك محققا عدليا قبل المحقق
البيطار كان المحقق فؤاد
استهدف بالطريقه نفسها بطلبات الرد وغيرها
وبالتهامات السياسيه انه يريد ان همم
التحقيق باتجاه اصابه حزب الله وفريقه
السياسي ومن بعض ذلك ادى المحقق البيطار
واستمر هذا الاستهداف وهنا ماذا تتحدث عن
اليه قانونيه نتحدث عن سلسله تصريحات
لامير عام حزب الله
تخون القاضي البيطار وتتهمه بالعمل لصالح
امريكا واسرائيل وتوجيه التحقيق باتجاهات
سياسيه معينه وبعد ذلك راينا ايضا ان
مسؤولا كبيرا في حزب الله يدخل الى قصر
العدد ويهدد بالمباشر القضاه ويقول حرفيا
من الطي راس البطار وبالتالي هذا الصياد
يشير الاستهداف سياسي وليس عمليا عمليا
همم قضائيه
منذ اسابيع منذ اسبوعين راينا كيف تم
استهداف اهالي ضحايا واستدعائهم للقضاء
للتحقيق معهم وايضا هذا يمكن وضعه في هذا
السياق ان العمليه هناك من يريد مسح
التحقيق او تدمير هذا التحقيق لكي ينضم
ملف
المرمى مثل كل الجرائم السياسيه التي
شهدها لبنان السيد طارق عبود نعم حتى
اليوم 15 جريمه سياحيه لا يوجد فيها اي
تحقيق ولم يتم التوصل الى اي معطيات لماذا
تخشى السلطه السياسيه هذا التحقيق لماذا
حزب الله كان اول من وجه سهامه الى هذا
التحقيق والى المحقق ما الذي يخشاه الحزب
من همم من تحقيقات انفجار بيروت
هلا اول شيء حزب الله ليس متهما في انفجار
مرفا بيروت المتهمون كانوا نوابا من حركه
امل وليس من حزب الله ليس هناك اي اتهام
لحزب الله في هذا الموضوع يعني وزير
الماليه علي حسن خليل ووزير الاشغال غازي
زعيتر من حفظ الالقاب
والوزير الفنيانوس والوزير المشنوق الذين
اتهمهم القاضي بيطار لا ينتمون الى حزب
الله السرديه التي يقولها الاستاذ طوني
وبعض يعني او كثير من ال- اا من السياسيين
او الاعلاميين هي سرديات يعني لا لا اساس
لها
عندما كان السيد حسن يقول ان ان القضاء
والتحقيق مسيس لانه هناك دلائل وشهود
كثيره على ان هذا التحقيق مسيس وهناك تخبط
في في التحقيق همم طيب اذا سالنا هلا
اليوم في ما حصل مؤخرا يعني ما همم يعني
ما يستجد حقيقه لكي يعود القاضي بيطار الى
متابعه ملف التحقيق بعد ان كفه يده
لحوالي ثلاثه عشر شهرا بعد رفع 50 دعوه
بحقه طيب اثنين لماذا همم يتهم او يستدعي
همم يعني رئيس حكومه سابق ولم يستدعي رؤوس
رئيس حكومه حالي لماذا استدعى همم قائد
جيش سابق ولم يستدعي قائد جيش حالي لماذا
استدعى وزير ماليه صادق الى اخره يعني
هناك كثير من التخبط في هذا التحقيق اثنين
ما هو المصور القانوني اليوم لكي يستعيد
القاضي بيطار صلاحياته ويعود الى التحقيق
ثلاثه كيف يعني يكون يعني لماذا اليوم
اصبح العام النائب العام هذه
جرى جرى الكثير الحديث عنها
الاسئله همم
وجهه نظر مغيره ايذاءها ولكن نقطه اود
التطرق اليها وهو الموقوف ذي الجنسيه
الامريكيه من ال عوف الذي اطلق سراحه وخرج
مباشره من السجن الى الطائره فالولايات
المتحده تردد ان كل هذه الامروجه سيد طوني
بولس هو للوصول الى اطلاق سراح همم هذا
الامريكي بطلبا من السفيره الامريكيه طلب
كان معروف ما رايك باختصار
يعني مما لا شك ان كان هناك ضغوط امريكيه
تجاهه اطلاق سراح الموقوف من الجنسيه
الامريكيه زياد العوف ولكن لا اعتبر ان كل
ما حصل هو بهذا السياق ولكن هذا السياق
الاستفاده منه زياد العوف وال الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه علما ان كان هناك
بالفعل تهديدات امريكيه مباشره انها
ستستخدم يعني قانون الرهائن وستعتبر
الموقوف في لبنان منذ سنتين دون محاكمه هو
رهينه وستعمل في هذه الاطار قضيه
الموقوفين في هذا الملف ربما هناك جزء
منها انسان يجب ان يبات يعني من غير
المنطقي ومن غير القانوني ان يبقى على ذمه
التحقيق اشخاص موقوفين لمده عامين ونصف
وهذا ما سببه توقف التحقيق في يد البيطار
لذلك انا كنت اشيلا ان القضيه تدخل
السياسي في القضيه ظلم الكثير من الموقفين
ويجعلهم معتقلين ظلما وايضا ضرب تحقيق
وجعل من اهالي الضحايا الضحيه ضحيه مره
ثانيه ولم يحقق ولم تصل الى الحقيقه في
قضيه او في انفجار صنف من اكبر انفجارات
شكرا العالم او في التاريخ حتى لذلك هنا
تحدث ان التاسيس هو من ضرب القضاء
طارق عبود ايضا الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
في انحاء مختلفه من اوكرانيا كثفت القوات
الروسيه ضربتها الصاروخيه ونقلت وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه عن مصادر طبيه اوكرانيه
ان احد عشر شخصا قتلوا اليوم جرى ضربات
الروسيه وكانت سلطات في كيا اف قد قالت ان
القوه الروسيه استهدفت العاصمه باكثر من
خمسه عشر صاروخ كروس
القياده العسكريه في كييف تصدي الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه للصواريخ الروسيه التي
وجهت للمدينه ودفعت العمليات بعدد كبير من
السكان الى النزول الى الملاجئ والبقاء
فيها بعد تاكيد المجلس الاقليمي في قياده
ضربات الجويه لم يكن قد انتهى ذلك
اكدت الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه حجه القوات
الاوكرانيه الى مزيد من المدفعيه بعيده
المدى لضرب تعزيزات الروسيه التي تصل من
شبه جزيره القرم وقالت ان الروس ينقلون
ذخيره وعتادا الى مستودعات تبعد عن خطوط
الجبهات الجنوبيه اكثر من 80 كلم
الروس بمواصله نقل التعزيزات العسكريه من
شبه جزيره القرم الى جنوب اوكرانيا على
صعيد الدعم الغربيه اعلنت وزيره الدفاع
الكنديه
سترسل اربعه دبابات من طراز اثنين و200
عرب مدرعه الى اوكرانيا من جانبه اعتبر
لكريم لان القرارات التي اعلنتها واشنطن
وعواصم غربيه لاوكرانيه تشكل الانخراطا
مباشر
على تورط الامريكي والاوروبي المباشر
والمتزايده في الحرب المتحدث باسم
الكرملين قل لا لا ايضا من تاثير عادات
العسكريه الجديده على القتال بين الجانبين
الروسي والاوكراني تقرير ماجد عبد الهادي
اوروبا الغربيه ومن خلفها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بدت اخيرا كانها تمطر
دبابات قتاليه متطوره على الطرق المؤديه
الى ارض اوروبا الشرقيه
مكثفه مع حلفائنا وشركائنا الدوليه
31 دبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا
بالنظر الى سياق الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
في مواجهه الغزو الروسيه منذ ما يقرب من
سنه ثانيه بين ان الهدير المتعاليه من
عشرات وربما مئات الدبابات التي قد يستغرق
نقلها الى تخمر روسيا بضعه الشهور وكذا ما
اثارت من الغبار الكثيف في اوساط
الدبلوماسيه الدوليه قبل ان تحط جنازها
على التراب الاوكرانيه
كفيين لايقاظ ارثن من حروب الامبراطوريه
وعالميه طالما ظن الاوروبيون بان قارتهم
تجاوزتها الى غير رجعه صحيح ان الزمن
نتغير عما كان عليه حين اتجهت الدبابات
الالمانيه لتغزو روسيا في مستهلي
اربعينيات القرن الماضي وصحيح ان
الجغرافيا تغيرت ايضا ومعاها تغيرت
التحالفات الدوليه لا سيما بعد انتهاء
الحرب البارده لكن ردود الفعل الاوليه
التي بذلت من موسكو اذا اما يمكن وصفه
بشتاء الدبابات الغربيه ابقت الباب مفتوحا
على احتمالات خطيره في ربيع السنه الثانيه
من الحرب هذه خطه محكوم عليها بالفشل
والدبابات ستحترق قال لك كريم لان بينما
قالت سفارته لدى برلين ان القرار
الالمانيه يرفع الصراع الى مستوى جديد وان
المانيا تتخلى بموجبها عن مسؤوليتها
التاريخيه نح روسيا في اشاره اردت التذكره
على ما يبدو بالنتائج التي ادت اليها
هزيمه النازيه امام الجيش الاحمر في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وان من دون ان يفضح
قائلها الروس عن المقصود بذلك على وجه
الدقه سؤال الجدول المتوقعه من ارسال
الدبابات الغربيه الى اوكرانيا لم يعد هو
الحال هذه مجرد سؤال تقنيه يتعلق بتاثير
المتغير الجديد على الميزان العسكري
لحربها مع روسيا قدره ما يعكس نجاح اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدن في اعاده العواصم
الاوروبيه الكبرى الى حظيره التوافق شبه
الكامل مع سياسه واشنطن بعد شهور من
التردد الالماني الناجمه عن الحاجه الملحه
لوالدات الطاقه الروسيه لا بل بعد السنوات
من التقارب المشهود الذي سبق لموسكو ان
حققته في علاقتها مع كل ان من برلين
وباريس بفضل اوام الاقتصاديه اهمها مشروع
خط الغاز العملاق نورد ستريم 2 الذي توقف
بعد ايام من الحرب كان انبوب الغاز الشهير
يوشك على التحول الى جسر بين روسيا ودول
غربي اوروبا حين تصاعد التوتر في شرق
اوكرانيا الى درجه استحدثت الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتن ليدفع بجيشه نحو اجتياح
الجاره فيما سماها عمليه عسكريه هدفها
استئصال من وصفهم بالنازيين هناك وهي
عمليه تحولت شيئا فشيئا الى ما يشبه حرب
استنزاف او الى فاخر استراتيجيه وفق بعض
التقديرات ثم ها هي توشك على دخول سنتها
الثانيه وقد حل الدبابات ليوبار الالمانيه
محل انبوب روسيه عنواننا لعلاقه روسيا مع
بلدان غربي القاره في قرينه ترجح خساره
القيصر الروسي معركه الهيمنه والنفوذ امام
الامبراطوريه الامريكيه وقد تنظر بما لا
تحمد عقباها على الامن العالمي ان واصل
اعدائه المواجهه حتى هزيمته
[موسيقى]
شدد رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
خلال لقائه رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي
احمد في الخرطوم على ضروره تعزيز التعاون
والتنسيق بين البلدين واكد البرهان خلال
جلسه المباحثات بين الجانبين في الخرطوم
ان الخرطوم
متوافقتان ومتفقتان بشان جميع القضايا
المتعلقه بسد النهضه وقال بيان المشترك
سوداني اثيوبيا زياره ابي احمد تهدف
للوقوف مع حكومه وشعب السودان في ازمه
الحاليه بما يفضي الى تحول الديمقراطي
والوصول للانتخابات وكان رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبيه قد التقى الاطراف السياسيه
السودانيه الموقعه هو غير الموقعه على
الاتفاق الايطالي السياسي لحفلها على حل
خلافاتها والعمل على تحقيق التوافق
والاستقرار
وضع رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيه ابي احمد
القوى السياسيه في السودان للتوافق من اجل
وضع حلول سودانيه للازمات التي تعيشها
البلاد جاء ذلك خلال مؤتمر صحفي لرئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبيه مع رئيس مجلس السياده
في الخرطوم
الاول
تتطلب تسامحا وحلولا توافقيه
المهم والينا من الخرطوم الدكتور عثمان
التون وزير الري السودانيه السابق ومن
القاهره عطيه يساوي الخبير في شؤون
الافريقيه وابدا معك سيد عطيه عيساوي مصر
كيف تنظر الى زياره ابي احمد
للسودان والاعلان عن الاتفاق او ان
البلدين السودان واثيوبيا متفقتان على
القضايا المتعلقه بسد النهضه
يعني اعتقد ان مصر همم يعني همم ستوافق او
فقط او همم راضيه عن زياره رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبي للسودان لان ذلك من شانها ان
يخفف التوتر بين البلدين فيما يتعلق
بقضايا همم الحدود المختلفه عليها هو
القضايا الاخرى مثل الذين
في همم السودان وغيرها من المشاكل اما
فيما يتعلق بسد النهضه اعتقد ان تصريح
رئيس المجلس ال همم السياده السوداني فيما
يتعلق بان البلدين مستقيمان على كل
القضايا المتعلقه بسد النهضه اعتقد ان لم
يكن هناك همم تفسير اخر همم سري او اتفاق
سري اعتقد ان انه يريد ان يقول انه
البلدين متفقان على حل كل هذه القضايا
سلميا وليس عن طريق الايه الحرب او
العنفذه اما اذا كان الامر غير ذلك فمعنى
ذلك سيكون ان السودان تراجع عن اتفاق مع
مصر بضروره ان همم يتم الا يتم ملئ و
تشغيل سد النهضه الا بالتفاق البلدين همم
البلدان الثلاثه مصر والسودان واثيوبيا
وايضا ان يتم الاتفاق اولا على كيفيه همم
مواجهه حالات الجفاف والجفاف الممتاز وعلى
ضروره الاتفاق الى الاتفاق على اتفاق ملزم
للبلدان الثلاثه وايضا على اليه لفضل
خلافات عندما تظهر عند التطبيق
السؤال هذا السؤال المطروح على الدكتور
عثمان توم هل تراجع السودان عن هذا فاق ان
لا يتم ملئ سد النهضه بالكامل الا
بالاتفاق الثلاثي بين مصر والسودان همم
اثيوبيا
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه ومرحب بيك ومرحب
بك من المشاهدين
والضيف الكريم انا لا اظن عند اي اتفاق
بين
اثيوبيا والقرطوم سيكون سلبا على مصر لان
بالنسبه للسودان السوداني يحتاج لمعلومات
يوميه واسبوعيه وشهريه وسنويه لكيفيه
تشغيل سد النهضه حتى يستطيع ان ينظم اا
تشغيل السدود
ومشاريع الزراعيه التي تعتمدها اعتماد
اساسي على ذلك مصر لديها سد العالي يكفيها
مئونه همم
تذبذب الايراد الطبيعي للنيل لكن سوداني
يحتاج الى هذه المعلومات السودان همم وهذا
همم يعني منصوص عليه وحتى في اتفاق همم
اتفاق الاطار في سنه
2015 بان تكون هناك
لجنه تنسيقيه بين الدول الثلاثه لتنظم همم
العمل في موضوع شد الدمام
من كلامك افهم وكان السودان قد فك هذا
الارتباط المتعلق تحديدا
بالموقف من سد النهضه قد فك هذا الارتباط
مع مصر وذهب منفردا للتوافق مع اثيوبيا هل
هذا صحيح باختصار ارجوك
لا لا ليس صحيحا لان الاتفاق على تبادل
المعلومات والتنسيق في تشغيل المنظومه
يفيد مصر ولا يضرها يعني حتى يمكن السدود
في السودان وكذلك سد العالي يمكن ان يعمل
بمناسب اقل من المناصيب الحاليه
لتنظيم لانه سد النهضه ينظم الاراده
الطبيعي الاراده الطبيعي
للنيل وكذلك حتى بالنسبه همم في نظري سد
النهضه يساعد في موضوع الجفاف والجفاف
المستمر لانه
يولد نفس توليد الكهربائي المائي كل سنه
وبالتالي اذا كانت الاراده النيل الازرق
همم متدني في سنه معينه ياخذ من
التخزين الاحتياطي الموجود لديه
هنا واضحه
واضحه بوضوح الشمس ايه سيد عطيه عيساوي ما
رايك بما ذكره السيد عثمان توم
يعني فيما يتعلق بالتبادل المعلومات كان
هذا مطلب الرئيسيه للسودان وعياداتهم مصر
خلال عمليات الملك الاولى والثانيه
والثالثه
وللاسف اثيوبيا استجابت جزئيه لهذا الامر
ورفضت في امور اخرى مما ادى الى سطح
المياه في فتره عن السودان ثم همم زيادتها
بشكل ادى الى فيضان وقمر المناطق المحيطه
بالنيل الازرق في الاراضي السودانيه
بالمياه مصر لا تعارض ان يتم حل المشاكل
الساده بالطرق السلميه وهذا مات عيناي
اليه فضلا عن ان مصر اقترح حتى تشغيل السد
همم بخطه معينه صراحتها على اثيوبيا بحيث
يعمل بنسبه 80% من طاقته في اسوء حالات
الجفاف ومع ذلك رفضت اثيوبيا الاقتراح كل
ذلك تمسكا بما
وبالسياده
متنسيه او متجاهله ما ينص عليه القانون
الدولي من ضروره التنسيق بين الدول
المتشاطئه على نهر واحد حتى لا تتضرر اي
منها من اي تصرف من دوله المنبع جزيلا
خطيئه يساوي من القاهره الخبير في شؤون
الافريقيه وشكرا ايضا للدكتور عثمان التوم
وزير الرئيس السودانيه السابق من الخرطوم
اعتذرت الخارجيه الفرنسيه امانه وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه الى بروف بدعم باريس
للارهاب اكاذيب مخزيه الترشوب بتصيحات
سبحانه وتنافس والصراع على الحضور في
القاره الافريقيه حيث يتزامن تراجع عن
نفوذ الفرنسي وخروج باريس من عدد من الدول
مع تزايد واضح للوجود الروسيه في افريقيا
خصوصا في منطقه الساحلي والصحراء
اكاذيب مخزيه تلك هي العباره التي اختارت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان
تستخدمها لوصف تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجيو لافروف قبل يومين والتي لم
يكتفي فيها بانتقاد ما اعتبره تدخلا
فرنسيا في الشؤون الداخليه للدول
الافريقيه بل اتهم باريس بتعزيز الارهابي
في القاره السمراء من خلال دعمها من وصفهم
بالارهابيين في ليبيا
تصريحات راس الدبلوماسيه الروسيه التي
اطلقها خلال جوله له في دول افريقيا
جاءت هي بدورها ردا على تعليق لرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون في الثالث
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري اجاب فيها عن
رايه بالطلب بوركينا فاسو من قوات بلاده
مغادره اراضيها الرئيس ماكرون ساره عبي
توجيه اصابع اتهام وان بطريقه غير مباشره
الى موسكو بالوقوف وراء ذلك الطلب فالروس
برايه متخصصون بالتلا في تلك المنطقه ولا
سينما ان الطلب حكام المستعمره الفرنسيه
السابقه جاء بعد ايام قليله على احتجاجات
شعبيه طالبت برحيل الجنود الفرنسيين متهمه
اياهم باتخادم في حمايه المدنيين من
الجماعات المسلحه وهي ترفع الاعلام
الروسيه رغم ان العلاقات بين موسكو وباريس
تمر اصلا بحاله من التوتر بسبب الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا والتصاعد الدعم
العسكري الغربي لكيف فان لهذه التجاذبات
الدلاله اعمق داخل المشهد الافريقي
وتحديدا اكثر فيما تعرفه بدول الساحل
فمقابله ما يمكن وصفه بالافول الفرنسيه
هناك يحضر تمدد الروسي لا تخطئه العين سبق
ان حدث هذا في مالي قبل اشهر واليوم
ايتكرر في بوركينا فاسو اذ لا يستبعد ان
يحل مقاتلوا ميليسا فاجنر بدلا من الجنود
الفرنسيين الذين ينتظر ان يغادروا اراضيها
خلال شهر واحد
[موسيقى]
وزاره الاسرائيليه الجديده
على مساحه اقل من نصف كيلو متر مربع في
ابريل عام 2002 فرض الجيش الاحتلال حصارا
قاسيا على المخيم وادت الفصائل الفلسطينيه
والمسلحون مقاومه شرسه اسفلت عن مصرعي
ثلاثه 20 جنديا اسرائيليا واستشهاد 52 فلس
ادى ذلك الاشتياح الى تدمير شبه كامل
لمخيم جنين وتشريد الالاف لاحقا اسرائيل
وعرقله عاده اعمار المخيم المنكوب بل
واغتالت المدير الامميه لمشروع الاعمار
البريطاني اين هوك في عام 2022 زادت وتيره
عمليات اقتحام المخيم وكان ابرزها في
ابريل عندما اعتقل جيش الاحتلال شبانا
فلسطينيين وقتل واصاب اخرين اصبح مخيم
جنين حاضنه المقاومه في الضفه حيث دمج
مقاتلوا حركتي حماس والجهاد الاسلامي مع
مقاتلي كتائب شهداء الاقصى التابعه لحركه
فتح عندما في مجموعات موحده ابرز كتيبه
جنين
وشكل تلك الفصائل غرفه عمليات مشتركه في
المخيم وهو ما مكانها من تنفيذ عده عمليات
الناجحه ضد الجنود الاحتلال والمستوطنين
في مخيم جنين
كتيبه علامه فارغه للمقاومه في الضفه
الغربيه الا وهي كتيبه جنين التي شكلت
هاجسا لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ظهرت كتيبه جنين للعنان اسرى فراري سته
اسرى من سجن جلبوع اوائل سبتمبر من عام
2021 حيث تعهدت بحمايتهم حاله قدومهم الى
الجنه
تتشكل هذه الكتيبه من مجموعات قتاليه شابه
وتعتمد على اسلحه خفيفه
وعبوات محليه التصنيع
وقد تمكن الاحتلال من اغتيال عدد من
عناصرها منهم احمد السعدي وجميل العموري
وسائط عباهره وعبد الله الحصري وخليل
طوالبه وغيرهم
الينا من غزه حسن لافي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مرحبا بك سيد حسن
لماذا جنين لماذا هذا المخيم وما الذي
يميزه عن غيره من الاماكن الفلسطينيه التي
تشهد حالات مقاومه ولكن في جنين تتركز هذه
الحالات بشكل اكثر وضوحا
هناك عده عوامل بالمناسبه اولها ان اعتقد
العامل النفسي روح المخيم روح مخيم جنين
الذي يشكل الوحده الفلسطينيه الذي يشكل
الوحده الفلسطينيه من خلال ان الجميع من
في المخيم يعانون اللجوء يشعرون نفس
الامور لديهم رابطه اسريه عائليه وطنيه
اكبر من كثير من اي انقسامات سياسيه او
عيد لوجيه وبالتالي مفهوم الوحده الوطنيه
في جنين بشكل اساسي الامر الثاني انا
اعتقد اسطوره مخيم جنين ومعركه المخيم عام
2002 الذي سجلت بها الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وحضور فردا واسطوريا وجعل من هذه النموذج
نموذج يحتذى به لدى كل الابطال ايه مخيم
جنين وباتت نوع من انواع لهذا في
الفلسطينيه الذي الجميع يحاول ان يكررها
فاصبحت نموذج ملهما الان هؤلاء الشباب من
كتيبه جنين
والكتائب الاخرى همم تريد ان ان ان ان
تعيد هذا هذه الاسطوره في جنينه الامر
الثالث له علاقه بالسياسه
السلطه الفلسطينيه رغم يعني انها يعني
حركه فتح حاضره في المخيم بشكل كبير ولكن
نهج السلطوي الذي له علاقه بالتنسيق
الامني والضبط الحاله الامنيه همم غير
قويه في منطقه شمال الضفه الغربيه هناك
نوع من انواع التمرد داخل قواعد حركه فتح
على نهج التسويه ونهج التنسيق الامن
وبالتالي العلاقات الفصليه اكبر بكثير من
من الانقسامات وبالتالي يعني كما ذكر
تقريركم ان همم سرايا القدس تابع حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي كتائب شهداء الاقصى كتائب
القسام كلها في اطار طاقه واحده بعيدا عن
الانقسامات السياسيه التي تعيشها الحاله
الفلسطينيه
ثالث استطاعت سرايا القدس ان تشكل كتيبه
جنينه واستطاعت شهداء الاقصى ان تشكل حاله
عسكريه حزام النار وايضا كتائب القسام
حاضره بعيدا عن الصوت والامنيه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه الامر الاخير ايضا طبيعه همم
طبيعه شمال الضفه الغربيه
يعني خاصه جنين انها بعيده كل البعد عن
المستوطنات وبالتالي القبضه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه ايضا همم وكلنا نتذكر في عام
2005 من السحاب من مستوطنه حومش وبعض
المستوطنات المحيطه بجنن وهذا الدليل على
ان ايضا قبل الاسرائيليه الامنيه ليست
قويه في هذه المنطقه كل هذه العوامل تؤكد
ان المخيم هنا بان يكون اسطوره المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ولكن همم
القبضه الامنيه الاسرائيليه همم ليست بهذه
القوه لكنه مستهدفه وهو هدف مستمر لقوات
الاحتلال كما يبدو وكما نتابع بشكل همم
شبه يومي هنا السيد حسن لا في
دمر مخيم جنين في عام 2002 يعني يكاد يكون
قد امر عن فكره ابيه وتمنع اسرائيل اعاده
اعماره وتعرقل عمليه اعاده الاعمار ولكن
همم رغم ذلك يستمر على نفس النهج لبن اقوى
من ذلك على ما يدل همم هذا الامر كان همم
من الناحيه الاسرائيليه التي لم تستطع
الغاء المقاومه بداخله او من الناحيه
الفلسطينيه التي تصر رغم الدمار على همم
البقاء في خط المقاومه
بالتاكيد الاراده الفلسطينيه اراده قويه
وخاصه عندما يتكلم عن روح المخيم يعني
هناك
تصميم من قبل الشعب الفلسطيني ان يبقى
حاضرا وقضيه حاضره وكيف تبقي القضيه حاضر
الا من خلال المقاومه الامر الثاني انا
اعتقد له علاقه بالاحتلال نفسه
القضيه ليست مباني او تشكيلات سكانيه
معينه القضيه هناك احتلال لم يتغير شيء
على مخيم جنين منذ عام 2002 الاحتلال هو
هو القبضه الامنيه للاحتلال والاستيطان
والتهويد هي هي الشعب الفلسطيني الذي يعيش
او الفئه السكانيه التي تعيش داخل المخيم
ايضا تبحث عن عن تطوير نفسه ولكن هناك
اصطدام كما اصطدام محمود طوالبه قائد
سرايا القدس في عام 2002
بالاحتلال يصطدم جميل العموري بالاحتلال
يصطدم همم محمد السادس بالاحتلال اذا
الاحتلال ما دام الاحتلال حاضر سيبقى روح
المخيم حاضر وروح المقيمه هي روح المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وكلنا نعلم ان الثوره
الفلسطينيه انطلقت من المخيمات هذه هي
قضيه اللجوء قضيه اساسيه في الفكر الفكر
السياسي الفلسطيني وفي الذهنيه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي حتى عندما حاولت
اسرائيل العرق قالت الاعمار لكي تشتت هذه
الفئات السكانيه بشكل كبير لم تستطيع لان
روح المخيم اكبر بكثير من الغطرسه
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي نحن الان نشاهد
جزيلا ويسجل اخرى همم
وقتنا شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من غزه
مشاهدينا نهايه الحصاد نشكر متابعتك